as an artist I like to make functional
art I just kind of liked the idea of
keeping skateboard skateboards my idea
was keep them out of the landfill and
keep them under your feet
well this thing's absolutely beautiful
and I love the idea that you're taking
old skateboards and making them into new
skateboards but what I really would love
to find out is how you actually make
these well it first starts right here
you collect all these broken boards and
you get to peel the grip tape off and
you get to grind all these beautiful
graphics off that's the part where I'll
actually end up taking pictures because
then like the way a skateboard is used
that's art to me I think that's
beautiful yeah anyway I kill the board's
I grind them I get them ready to be
glued and then cut over here and my
cutting room is where I do all my
cutting how many boards can you make out
of one of these stacks it's all depends
on width but they're good numbers like
12 to 14 boards
once you get to the plank cut then
what's the next step I grabbed one of my
mini templates right here I'll just
match it right up
once I trace the shape I'll just take a
quick jigsaw cut and then I get it right
to the line on this sander right here
so once the boards are cut out to their
shape we we blast them I use recycled
crushed glass for the top so I basically
just sprinkle on the crushed glass
broadcast it along the surface and it
gives you enough grip to ride you've got
this inventive spirit you're empowered
with tools and workshop and you've
figured out ways to build new
skateboards out of old skateboards and I
think that there's something that's
really that DIY energy that
skateboarding fostered because we had to
figure out how to make our own way
through it do you still see that I do
see it and I live it all my good friends
even though their skate parks around we
still build our own spots like anytime
you come upon some unused land and you
have some extra money and you want to
throw some concrete around it's done as
it's being done as we speak around here
what's the closest skatepark you've
built
oh my backyard
I think that as skateboarders we have
the ability to use our creativity to do
something with our waste rather than
just kind of toss it aside making this
brand new doesn't that's not the point
to me you know you can make this brand
new you could actually make a board just
like this with concave look like this
brand new but that's not what I do every
time I look at these I think each one of
these boards has well apparently 222
individual stories
there's 22 decks in here written by
someone and having experience having fun
laughing playing this is a really
beautiful project thank you and a lot of
ways skateboarders love their
skateboards you know no matter how you
go through like four skate boards a
month you loved all those boards and
here's the proof yeah this is the story
right here